mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos wünschte ihnen viel vergnügen
ein mann legt sich gefesselt auf die
straße mitten in moskau eine kunstaktion
die auf die entdeckung getöteter
zivilisten im kiewer vor ort butscher
aufmerksam machen will das unmittelbare
zitieren der realität zeigt wirkung aber
ist sie nachhaltig muss kunst im krieg
politisch sein um reale bilder wie diese
in zukunft zu verhindern
diesen fragen gehen wir nach
jetzt im kultur platz
[Musik]
kriegsbilder waren mehr als im
sechzehnten jahrhundert ein mittel zur
abschreckung hier die pariser
bluthochzeit von françois de buhr es
zeigt die bartholomäusnacht
1572 als in frankreich hausen der
protestanten ermordet wurden wir kommen
auf dem kulturplatz ja was kann was muss
die kunst leisten in kriegszeiten das
fragen hier heute und wir treffen
kunstschaffende aus der ukraine und
zeigen die ihre werke aktuell bis zur
biennale in venedig gelangen können und
wir machen station hier im museum tonal
der user in lausanne hier gibt es
aktuell eine ausstellung zu sehen zu
kunst und widerstand kann die kunst
helfen das trauma des krieges zu
überleben das haben wir den ukrainischen
künstlerpaar kopf gefragt er vertritt
dieses jahr seine heimat bei der
prestigeträchtigsten kunstausstellung
der welt bei der biennale in venedig
allerdings war bis vor kurzem nicht klar
ob es mag oft bis dorthin schaffen würde
denn er saß in seiner heimat in einem
bunker fest
in den 63 jahren meines lebens ist es
mir noch nie passiert dass raketen über
meinem kopf abgefeuert werden ich habe
noch nie erlebt dass meine stadt
zerstört wird in acht tagen sogar die
zivilen quartier das hätte ich nie
erwartet
nun ist pablo markov 2000 kilometer
entfernt von den gräueln des krieges
er und die kuratorin maria langkow haben
es nach venedig geschafft und bespielen
an der biennale den ukrainischen papier
ein wichtiger beitrag für die identität
ihres landes
ich fühle mich zurzeit nicht als
künstler sondern vielmehr als bürger der
die pflicht hat das für sein land zu tun
die ukraine muss repräsentiert werden
nichtig
pablo markov geboren im russischen sankt
petersburg lebte vor dem krieg im
nordosten des landes interaktiv mit 1,5
millionen einwohnern die zweitgrößte
stadt der ukraine hier arbeiteten vor
kriegsausbruch wichtige zeitgenössische
kunstschaffende des landes einer der
bekanntesten ist paloma kopf
sein werk umfasst hunderte von
radierungen drucke zeichnungen skizzen
und skulptur
markovs kunst ist in vielen museen und
sammlungen zu finden in der ukraine und
im ausland
[Musik]
doch dann kam der krieg und legte die
pulsierende kulturstadtrat in schutt und
asche
fordert unzählige zivile opfer
als das zentrum der stadt beschossen
wird ergreift pablo markov mit seiner
frau und seiner mutter die flucht lässt
seine kunstwerke und seine heimat zurück
meine mutter wollte nicht in den bunker
sie sagte ich habe den zweiten weltkrieg
überlebt was jetzt geschieht ist noch
nicht fliehen und kümmert mich nicht
aber als ich sah was wirklich geschah
gestern sagte sie mir am telefon etwas
extremes sie sah die bilder von butscher
und sie sagte die deutschen haben solche
taten nicht begangen die deutschen waren
grausam schrecklich aber während des
ganzen weltkriegs habe ich solche dinge
nicht gesehen das kommt von meiner
mutter mit ihren 92 jahren
floh markov wurde eingeladen an der
biennale seine skulptur fountain of
exotischen akku alter brunnen der
erschöpfung hochwasser zu zeigen so soll
sein kunstwerk im ukrainischen pavillon
aussehen doch es gab ein problem
markovs verb befand sich noch in der
ukraine mitten in kiew die kuratorin
maria lankowitz mutig ihre hilfe an
wenn es nicht für den ballon gewesen
wäre dann wäre ich wohl nirgends hin
gegangen weil ich nicht versuchte mein
leben zu retten sondern unseren job zu
beenden
wir arbeiteten ein halbes jahr lang für
den bio investierten unsere
intellektuellen und finanziellen
ressourcen unser herz und unsere seele
es war sehr wichtig für unser team dass
wir es an die biennale schaffen würden
diese arbeit wollte das kuratorenteam
nicht verlieren
die zwei gründerinnen und gründer der
renommierten ukrainischen gallery the
medium beschlossen deshalb pablo markov
skulptur aus der gefahrenzone zu
evakuieren
maria lang und die einzelteile in den
kofferraum ihres autos
fuhr los richtung rumänien und filmte
die anstrengende reise
bis zur grenze vor ich mir sechs tage
normalerweise schafft man das in einem
tag aber die straßen waren verstopft es
ging alles sehr langsam
von rumänien ging es weiter bis nach
venedig
[Musik]
jetzt werden die einzelteile des
kunstwerks in einer werkstatt zur
skulptur fountain of xtreme
zusammengefügt
ich habe eine überraschung für sie das
ist ein trichter das hauptelement dass
kultur
sie besteht aus 78 trichtern die im
dreieck angeordnet sind das wasser
fließt in den obersten der teilt sich in
zwei und dann nochmal sind zwei und am
ende gibt es praktisch kein wasser mehr
es tröpfelt nur noch
fountain symbolisiert die lokale
zeitgenössische situation aber sie ist
auch ein symbol für die situation in der
welt
sie symbolisiert ein rad von erschöpfung
der menschlichkeit und neben dieser
großen erschöpfung der menschlichkeit
ist es auch eine erschöpfung unserer
beziehung zur natur unserer beziehungen
untereinander zwischen den ländern in
politik und ökonomie
fountain spricht die gründe an warum der
krieg überhaupt möglich wurde pablo
erwähnte die erschöpfung der
menschlichkeit aber zuvor gab es auch
schon die erschöpfung der demokratie die
es putin erlaubte die grenzen nicht mehr
zu respektieren und zu prüfen wie weit
er gehen kann er kann weitgehend wie wir
sehen
markus fountain wird dem ukrainischen
pavillon das einzige kunstwerk sein
ein ort der kontemplation um über die
erschöpfung der gesellschaft
nachzudenken doch was kann kunst konkret
bewirken
kunst beeinflusst das leben aber nur
langfristig
kunst kann nicht sofort ändern
ich denke kunst kann uns helfen das
drama zu überleben
kunst kann identität schaffen für eine
gewisse gruppe für ein land oder eine
gemeinschaft
wir hoffen dass die ukrainische kunst
fähig ist unsere identität darzustellen
die russen wollen die tatsache
auslöschen dass es die ukraine gibt als
land und als kultur
unsere kultur zu bewahren und sie zu
repräsentieren bezeugt dass wir
existieren es
ist sehr wichtig ein teil von europa zu
sein und als ort wahrgenommen zu werden
wo kultur spannend ist wo sie wächst und
wo viele interessante dinge geschehen
die biennale beginnt am 23
april was bamako von bary alanco danach
tun und wohin sie gehen werden das hängt
vom krieg unter situation in der ukraine
ab
[Musik]
barati fischer sie hand öffnet hier mit
der umstellung noch vor kriegsausbruch
der ukraine jetzt geht bald anders was
macht das mit ihrer arbeit ja das ist
natürlich das sind ganz andere
voraussetzungen vor allem versuchen wo
die ausstellung ganz anders auffassen
italiener und plötzlich sachen vun deene
kunstwerk eigentlich enthalten sind
dabei die werte dann mit silber
die
kontexte zweiten tag seiner arbeit vom
schweizer künstler fabry recht lukrativ
wird und jetzt zwar im ersten moment
merken sie da auch ein unterschied wie
das korsett rezeption von den
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer sich darauf
andere ja allerdings mit der öffnung
vertrauensstellung ist die skulptur
minimalistisch ist kultur card mit
hätten es auch lisa thoma solution und
so bitter
nötig dass ein anderer braucht mehr als
fünf schiffe fest binden und so weiter
und hört hat natürlich sofort an
stammtischen panzersperren ist ob er
schaut wenn wir nur das kunstwerk das
antibiotika
von mozilla vorgibt und der kontext vor
gebe es
anders als die panzersperre nämlich die
grenze gezogen wird wollte zu führen
dass sich nicht auf die andere seite hat
die dem zusammenhang muss mit dem taxi
danke sehr stark für viele menschen in
der ukraine ist krieg bereits seit 2014
eine schreckliche realität als putin die
krim besetzte und in der ausdruck reiner
die kämpfe begannen der talks in the us
is blues lorenz zeigt auf sehr
berührende weise das leben einer mutter
mit ihren vier kindern zu kriegszeiten
ist aktuell zu sehen beim dok film
festival wie sie unter allen
[Musik]
eine alleinerziehende mutter feiert
geburtstag mit ihren vier kindern und
freunden
eigentlich eine alltägliche szene aber
die familie lebt im umkämpften gebiet im
osten der ukraine
dort herrscht bereits 2014 krieg
pro-russische separatisten werden von
der ukrainischen armee seit jahren
bekämpft
in dieser realität arbeitet die familie
an einem drehbuch sie drehen einen film
über ihre erlebnisse im krieg und werden
dabei selbst für eine dokumentation
gefilmt
[Musik]
unter dem ungewöhnlichen titel dies ist
blue orange wurde der preisgekrönte film
der regisseurin irina celik aus kiew
weltweit gezeigt gedreht wurde 2017
[Musik]
sie fand die familie in einem film camp
für kinder im kriegsgebiet
als wir das haus sahen voll mit katzen
musik und gesprächen über kunst in
kriegszeiten
haben wir sofort gewusst dass wir den
fokus auf ein intimes porträt dieser
familie liegen wollten sie
versucht ihr leben trotz krieg voll
auszukosten
der film zeigt den versuch eines
normalen lebens im krieg
[Applaus]
er beleuchtet auch das erwachsenwerden
der ältesten tochter miroslava die ihren
schulabschluss macht ihr größter wunsch
an einer filmakademie aufgenommen zu
werden
die familie wohnt in einem fast
zerstörten baufälligen haus
eine seltsame stimmung hängt über dem
ort angespannt auch in den ruhigen
momenten
als ich mit der familie gedreht habe
empfand ich eine große empathie ihnen
gegenüber
ich reiste dann immer wieder zurück nach
kiew zu meiner familie in meine damals
friedliche welt und das war eine andere
realität
und jetzt hat sich alles komplett
verändert die ganze ukraine brennt
wenn es ums überleben geht scheint
zunächst kein platz für kultur zu sein
mit doris bures in orange versucht die
regisseurin trotzdem brücken zu bauen
im letzten monat habe ich gemerkt dass
kunst und film und mächtige werkzeuge
der kulturellen diplomatie gehen
wir können unsere filme in verschiedenen
ländern der welt zeigen
das gibt uns die möglichkeit mit anderen
menschen in den dialog zu treten
und ihnen zu helfen unsere realität aus
einer anderen perspektive zu sehen
für einmal gelingt die rena celik der
dialog aber nicht sie verweigert ihre
persönliche teilnahme am video die
regierung bleibt stattdessen in der
ukraine
sie möchte ein festival nicht auf
russische filmemacher treffen
vielleicht hörte sich krass an aber für
mich fühlt es sich so an als ob man
während des zweiten weltkrieges jüdische
filmemacher zusammen mit deutschen
filmemachern in einem programm zeigen
würde es ist nichts manipulativ gemeint
ich glaube das trifft es gut denn wir
erleben gerade einen russischen genozid
gegen ukraine
wir befinden uns jetzt im krieg
die us blue orange zeigt emotionale
ausschnitte aus einem schweren aber
manchmal auch schönen leben eine familie
die dem krieg durch kreativität und
zusammenhalt trotzt
übrigens hat das regisseurin vom film
zeit dass die familie mit kind jetzt in
litauer in sicherheit ist beinahe wie
bücher tags der arbeit von william
kentridge südafrika
der künstler krise aus ganz persönlicher
fragen autor william kentridge war ja in
johannesburg geboren und es ist ganz
locker verbracht hat kann natürlich
geschickt vor sieben sehr gut und hat
ein recht kritischen blick der beruf hat
mit einer ganzen anti apartheid
movements mitgemacht und verarbeitet
tipp sich natürlich
was nur so kann kunst leisten zurzeit
der krise zu ziehen was ist ihr
persönliches kunst
der frieden bringen kunst eigentlich
extra indirekt das bewusstsein schärfen
und rom ist kunst und literatur und
philosophie
absolut wertvoll und
lebensnotwendiges geht um mehr als um
den rhythmus von der militärische
marschmusik skater um poesie es geht um
ganz andere sachen wo sehr wichtig sind
[Musik]
der britische fotograf marc nervös vor
sich nie wieder einen fuß in ein
kriegsgebiet zu setzen zu groß war die
psychische belastung nach seinen
einsätzen in afghanistan
inzwischen lebt er will in seiner
wahlheimat der ukraine und hat sich nun
trotz allem doch wieder sehr intensiv
mit einem krieg auseinander gesetzt
[Musik]
fotos die vor ein paar monaten
entstanden sind
der krieg ist noch nicht da und ist es
doch
es ist mir egal ob ich meinem besitz
verliere ich habe alles zurückgelassen
was mir sorgen macht ist dass ich meine
freunde verliere dass sie ihre
familienmitglieder verlieren und dass
ich das gefühl von heimat verliere das
ich hatte denn danach hatte ich mein
ganzes leben lang gesucht und ich hatte
es in kiew in der ukraine gefunden
magna will hat die krisen der welt
fotografiert und wollte in der ukraine
den krieg hinter sich lassen doch der
hat ihn eingeholt
am morgen an dem der krieg begann das
war donnerstag der 24 bin ich in meiner
wohnung im zentrum von kiew aufgewacht
ich habe eine explosion und syrien
gehört und wusste sofort dass die
invasion begonnen hatte
[Musik]
mit seiner frau einer ukrainerin konnte
er sich über die grenze retten zum
interview schaltet er sich aus polen zu
am nächsten tag wird er nach kiew zurück
kehren
er muss einfach wie er sagt
[Musik]
dieser unglaubliche widerstandsfähigkeit
ist mir zum ersten mal bewusst geworden
als ich ein fotoprojekt über ukraine
gemacht habe die wegen des krieges im
don was viel mussten das war 2017 schon
damals wurden zweieinhalb millionen
vertrieben
dieser krieg ist schon vor acht jahren
ausgebrochen seitdem hat der westen
absolut nichts getan wir haben schon
darüber berichtet
in den gesichtern ist der krieg schon
angekommen bevor er die schlagzeile wert
[Musik]
ich erkenne das trauma in jedem selbst
bei den fotos aus kiew damals 600
kilometer von der front entfernt kann
man es sehen und spüren was mich aber am
meisten beunruhigt ist dass eine ganze
generation von menschen jetzt
vollständig traumatisiert wird die ganze
ukraine wird jetzt völlig traumatisiert
sein das kann man nicht mehr loswerden
es geht tief ist zerstörerisch
marvel ist selbst traumatisiert
2011 hellmann afghanistan er begleitet
als drehort ist britische
fallschirmjäger
[Musik]
und zerbricht beinahe an dem grauen das
er dokumentiert
[Musik]
als ich in afghanistan war hat den
offizier zu mir gesagt trauma
kriegstrauma das ist ungefähr so stell
dir vor man setzt eine katze auf ein
feld und lässt den ganzen tag um die
katze herum bomben fallen vielleicht
überlebt die katze aber sie wird nicht
mehr dasselbe tier sein und so ist es
auch mit den menschen
von level gibt es keine aktuellen fotos
aus der ukraine denn als kriegsfotograf
kann er nicht bearbeiten stockt panzer
mit büchern das ist ein friedensprojekt
es wird wenige tage vor ausbruch des
krieges fertig zu spät die idee war 750
exemplare an einflussreichen menschen zu
verschicken um den westen dazu zu
bringen den krieg mehr aufmerksamkeit zu
schenken
ich glaube mein lieblingsbild ist dieses
hier es ist dann der orthodoxen
beherrsche laura kirche in kiew
entstanden
drei kinder die durch den krieg in dem
bus vertrieben wurden und
sie haben einfach diese unglaublich
jungen und unschuldigen aber auch sehr
alten wissenden gesichter diese mischung
ist für mich sehr beunruhigend sie
mussten zu früh erwachsen werden
[Musik]
momentan kommen so viele erschütternde
bilder aus der ukraine
natürlich wegen des krieges und es ist
unheimlich wichtig dass diese bilder auf
der ganzen welt gesehen werden aber es
gibt so wenige bilder aus der ukraine
die ein gegengewicht zu bilden ich hoffe
also dass mein buch das alltagsleben in
der ukraine zeigen kann das leben vor
dem krieg
[Musik]
die ukraine
hat hunderttausende von fans viele davon
auch in russland seit krieg ist sind sie
kaum noch dafür packt sie in ihrer
heimat mit an dort wo sie gerade
gebraucht wird ja und ihre follower in
den sozialen medien die bekommen aktuell
weniger rap dafür informationen aus dem
krieg
[Musik]
aljona aljona
direkt ist ukraine die musikerin ist
doch ehrlich und kompromisslose art star
wurde
in ihrer videos setzt sie sich voll in
szene kämpft gegen stereotype und für
selbst akzeptanz auf instagram volk ihre
350 musikmanager und millionen von lead
user ihre musik wo der krieg jetzt aber
in ukrainischer abziehen sondern sie
nutzt ihre stimme zum social media
ich habe angefangen wie eine internet
soldatin zu arbeiten ich habe meiner
reichweite genutzt um über die
geschehnisse in der ukraine aufzuklären
[Musik]
in einer videobotschaft was auf
instagram teilt fordert sie ihre fans
oft davis russisch präsidenten vor ort
bringen soldaten in den krieg schicken
flucht ist für system ob sie sich zurück
zu einer älteren reist nach paris wo sie
auf praxis in der reportage verzweigt
sich 18 für thaliana durch ihre klebt
die plattenbausiedlung 70 kilometer von
kiew entfernt für ihre musikalische
durchbruch hatte dort als kindergarten
geschafft hätte ich die verkehr wieder
zurück zum ihrem vater bin medizin
transports halver aber die situation
setzt ihre zu und sie fühlt sich hilflos
es ist schrecklich ich muss viel weinen
weil ich den menschen die sterben nicht
helfen kann
die russische truppen zum glück nie bis
nach paris ifc schafft
um das russische militär von einem
einmarsch in mahndorf abzuhalten haben
die ukrainischen soldaten die zwei
brücken gesprengt die zu unserer
siedlung führen
ich möchte überall in europa benefiz
konzerte veranstalten um geld für die
ukrainische armee und für die
bevölkerung zusammen
ihre riesige popularität macht sie zu
einer identifikationsfigur und zum eine
idol in der ukraine zur musik machen und
sie sollte aber findet langsam wieder
energie mit einer videos wo hundertfach
gelegt werde fast sie der schmerz in
bildung und geklärt sie die hoffnung
ich weiß dass wir den krieg gewinnen
werden
ich hoffe dass kein kind auf der welt so
etwas wie krieg nie wieder erleben musst
es ist wirklich hart
ja die kunst kann keinen krieg
verhindern das ist klar aber sie kann
dem grauen ein gesicht geben sie kann
uns mut machen und sie kann uns zur
reflexion bringen und das alles ist viel
und das ist wichtig die ausstellung
widerstand leisten noch und noch hier
gemüse kantonal de posa in lausanne
läuft noch bis mitte mai
[Musik]
auf dem kulturplatz begrüßt sie nächste
woche meine kollegin nina wispo mit
neuen einsichten zu wilhelm tell der
dann vielleicht sogar zu einer
wilhelmine wird hier sehen uns im mai
wieder gute tage für sie
[Musik]
keine verhetzung
nie wieder krieg hin
in uns in mir
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen der kultur
swisslos